i want us to talk about money because i
think it's the perfect introduction to
the
sub topic that we're starting today okay
so first
let's do a bit of remembering okay in
our world
because it seems fair the more money
you've got
well how does it grow how does money
grow we have a formula for this right i
know there's
one that's simple uh and there's one
that's not so simple but i i think
simple is kind of silly
no money in the world actually grows the
way simple interest does
what is when normal money grows
we have a formula for this right what is
that with
good morning an a for amount however
much you start with
okay times what
one plus some kind of rate we call it an
interest rate don't we
right and then to the power of n
where n signifies how long have you been
there
okay so this is fine right
p4 by the way what is what is the p
generally for principal right how much
you actually are going to have by the
end of that time
now there's a couple of things i want to
do as we take apart this idea
okay firstly i want you to think about
this
hypothetical situation suppose i had a
thousand dollars
okay and i could put the one thousand
dollars in a bank account
or alternatively i could break it up
into
two chunks of five hundred dollars
and put them into two bank accounts a
thousand dollars in one account
or five hundred dollars into now
assuming they have the same rate at the
same time
which is a better deal having the 1 000
all in one place
or having them separated any thoughts
which one is better um
let's do it like this shall we uh
your two options are together or
separate
together or separate together separate
okay so on the count of three
i want you to say what you think is in
your head
okay it doesn't matter if you're wrong
it's just i want to see where you're at
okay so you're ready on the count of
three
together separate that's your there's
your two options okay one
two three oh we're pretty split weren't
we
okay is there anyone who didn't say
anything
anyone okay why not michelle
because you don't know okay anyone any
advance on is that the same reason for
you guys
it's okay it's an interesting idea oh
the answer is
the entry is well should we should we
give this a go should we actually test
out
what would happen give me give me an
interest rate give me a time let's work
this out let's go with the 1000 okay
principal start with a thousand dollars
what's the going rate these days free
interest per annum
who does economics six percent six
percent yeah
i don't know it sort of points around
doesn't it okay
there's my six percent how long should
we chuck it in there
five years sure why not okay i did tell
you to get your calculators out
what do we have
okay no bad return five years i suppose
okay
let's try this now so i'm gonna break it
apart into two
i've got my 500 over here
and then i have my 500 over here
and they're both in bank accounts for
the same amount of time with the same
interest
what do you get
oh oh you get 1338.20
what a surprise wait a second that's not
surprising the second
i wrote it down you could see it's not
surprising right because you can take
out a common factor
namely this stuff
and then you add your other two terms
together and oh you get a thousand
right okay interesting i i have to say
you know just personally it feels like
and i'll i'll test you on why this is
our instinct because a lot of you said
this
when you have it all together most of
you said
you'll get more interest this way not
everyone some of you went this way as
your own intuition for why that works
but neither is true it doesn't matter
where the dollars are
it doesn't matter how many piles they're
in it could be in a thousand past four
or like here right
if the same at the same time those are
the things that really matter that tell
you how fast things are going
okay all right so therefore taking that
as an idea
i now want to i hope you can see now it
doesn't matter how much money
i have i can actually consider all of
these dollars
on an individual basis is that okay does
that make sense so i'm not going to
worry too much about this
a up here okay what really matters
is let's just consider a one dollar
situation
because once i have a dollar everything
else behaves the same way okay just
multiply by a constant
now this thing here this money it is
growing
okay and we had this um this six percent
interest rate okay
that kind of made sense i want to test
out the idea
of something a sum of money not growing
at a six percent rate at a rate
proportional to a little fraction
okay but what if it was growing in
relation to
not part of it but all of it okay what
would the interest rate be
in such a case
if it's not just a fraction of the sub
that we're starting with
but the whole thing well hopefully it'd
be 100 wouldn't that
300 so to be something like this
okay now i know i could i we know what
one plus one is but i'm deliberately
separating these out
because i want you to see the part of it
this part here right what does that
signify when you have the one and then
you've got the .06 why do we include a
one there
because because that's the whole thing
if i didn't have the one there
this number i would end up with
something smaller wouldn't i okay so
this is kind of like your original part
and it sticks around right what's the
second number
it's it's the rate at which it grows so
even though they're both ones
right they mean different things okay
let's expand on this idea now you guys
know that
uh the quicker you grow right
or the more frequently you compound the
more you get
right now this idea we've visited before
but i want to make sure we
use this as our segue into the topic
okay so for instance
suppose i said look rather than every
time it
it's gonna well i guess it's gonna
double isn't it one two four eight
sixteen and so on
okay i wanna go down a little finer i
don't want discrete chunks of time okay
i want to
make it a little more frequent okay so
for instance
suppose i thought about things twice as
frequently okay twice as frequently
so what's going to happen in um
in the time period if we weren't say a
year to start with okay because
interest rates do tend to be per random
okay if we went six months
okay you're obviously not getting the
full 100
in that space type how much are you
getting
you're getting 50 aren't you that's a
half
okay now because there's um
more six month periods in a year right
this number reduces but
this number increases right so i should
have
2n up here yes okay
now let's just consider an example let's
just consider
the first year okay because like
considering the first dollar once you
have the way one works you can sort of
extrapolate from there
okay so for the case i'll do this in
green
for the case n equals one every time i
do something green will be n equals one
okay what is it after the first year in
this first situation
how much do i end up with the answer is
twice as much to start with started with
a dollar now i have two
okay what about here when n equals one
how much am i going to have in my
principle it'll be more right but how
much more
you have a calculator there right i
don't i don't know what uh
actually could you could you come on one
and a half we can't do this that'll be
two and a quarter two to four yes yes
yeah one and a half times two to the
power of two yeah good okay
so it's more right i wonder how how much
further we can push this
right let's go again let's do it
quarterly okay so when n equals one
all right my brain's starting to break
down here okay what is one point
two five to the power of four what do we
get
someone got the number it'll be some
decimal right
two point four four exact
keeps going okay that's all right that's
okay
now hold on a second just going from
here to here
we gained 0.25 didn't we maybe i put all
in decimal to compare them a bit more
easily
okay from here to here even though i
doubled the period i didn't get all that
much back did i what did i get
an extra 0.19 yeah
let's go another time let's double it
again
for n equals one what's one point one
two five
to the power of eight what do you get
2.5 i guess i guess seven
in that case okay i'm slowing down
aren't i now
we have language from calculus to
describe what's going on here right what
are we doing
we're taking a limit right we see what
happens
as this number gets smaller and this
number gets bigger at the same rate
yes okay so let's formalize this
the limit as what is this number really
there's a
one over round implied there right but
just so happens in that case
um n is one uh i'm taking limit as
sorry no not n some other number here
really let's call it um
let's call it x excellent
okay what's happening the rate's getting
but smaller time is getting bigger yes
okay so sorry there's no equals on it so
what's this limit equal to
what's going on here well you know what
this number we've already introduced
this idea before right what is the
number
it's it's well if i do a few decimal
places
that's about enough i think this number
emerges right this number is important
it's so important we call it e now just
think about this for a second you've
already established this you've worked
with this number already you already
know some of its characteristics right
but i want you to see where we got it
from i brought it back to this idea
of some kind of quantity
that's growing right but it's growing in
relation to
its own size does that make sense
uh it's not 0.06 right it's not just a
small part of it that defines how fast
it's growing
it's how big the thing is right and
obviously the bigger it is the faster it
will grow
okay so therefore this idea here
right this idea this is this the reason
why this number comes up and why it's on
your calculator
is because it's the number that tells us
about things that grow
quickly at a rate in proportion to their
size right
so let's get this idea down right e is
the number
describes
now we have a whole name for this don't
we so
let's introduce let's put a heading on
this before i give you the sentence
right
e it's e because it's what kind of
growth
exponential growth
is the number that describes exponential
growth
which is
growth that occurs
whoops now i want to try and bring
all of our language that we've noticed
in um applications of calculus to the
physical world to bear on this right
so i'm going to talk about that occurs
at a rate
and that rate idea tells us an important
calculus it's an important calculus
queue
for us right at a rate that is
proportional and that that id there that
word's really important that's why i'm
going to put it in caps in social media
that is proportional
to something's size
okay and the reason i started with money
is because we
intuitively get that the more money you
have
the faster it grows and i think that's
why
most of us said a thousand dollars
should grow faster shouldn't it
because we intuitively understand the
more you've got right the faster it goes
well it does grow faster than 500
individually just so happens when you
put them together they behave in the
same way
okay but here's the idea right
more money grows faster okay
less money grows slower
i put a lot of extra space on the end of
my um title because
exponential growth has a um has a sad
brother right which is this idea
but in reverse okay because it's not
only things that
grow that grow in relation to their size
okay but it's also things that shrink
right now when things shrink we call it
decay right and those of you who do
chemistry are very familiar with this
right
you got something and the more they
resolve it the faster it
goes away right and the classic example
of course is
radiation right radioactivity yeah the
more you've got of this substance
literally what's really radiating out is
the substance yeah
so it's going away and as they get less
of it it slows down
okay so this idea here
that a rate is proportional
to size okay
here's the sentence here's the idea
let's express it
in the language the notation that we're
familiar with
i had this thing we called it capital p
okay
um p often stands for things that grow
like principles all like populations is
the other common example of something
which the more people there are
not thinking about other constraining
factors like space and food and
disease and so on right the bigger
population is the faster it can grow
right so we're going to you're going to
encounter p a lot
what is the rate at which p changes in
terms of
our calculus language that we know how
would you say it
it'll be how the population is changing
well because it's rate it's over time
isn't it okay
okay so this is population change
principal change
whatever quantity change over time
now if something is proportional to
something else right
how is it related to that thing okay for
instance if i tell you
you know if you buy one donut it'll cost
you
you know two dollars because they're
really fancy krispy kreme donuts or
something like that okay
and if you buy 10 doughnuts it'll cost
you dollars and if you buy a hundred
donuts it'll cost you two hundred
dollars
how can we form this relationship right
like costs
and doughnuts these are proportional to
each other right can you tell i'm hungry
what kind of equation can i write here
the cost is well i i gave you two dollar
donuts didn't i
right so that'd be two times doughnuts
right
when two quantities are related by a
constant coefficient
okay this is what we call
proportionality okay
so if a rate is proportional to size i'm
going to introduce
a constant of some kind customarily
it's k
if dt is the rate that the population is
changing
what is the population's size or the
principal size whatever
it's just p isn't it there you go
okay i should probably say we just
talked about k
we said it's a constant
so it's uh let's introduce it like that
now this is really important put a nice
big colourful box around it okay
this is this is the exponential growth
and decay equation
okay we're going to talk about the the
sine of k shortly but i just want to get
across to you the idea
of this proportionality okay by the way
this is called
this thing has a name it's called a
differential equation
it's an equation that relates um a
quantity
to one of or multiple of its derivatives
okay